you might have heard about the robbery
at roseman's auction house what you
probably didn't but my sources confirm
is that the perpetrators were wearing
masks horrible demonic faces
yet another example of the explosion in
mass criminals since spider-man came on
the scene
let's hear your thoughts here on with
jay jonah jameson
yeah i see your point but spider-man
stopped those guys today saying he's
like them because he wears a mask isn't
fair it's like prejudice
wrong here's a little lesson in the
english language my friend
prejudice means to pre-judge someone
before you know anything about them i
know all i need to about spider-man he
runs around causing chaos wearing a mask
so he doesn't have to answer for his
shenanigans and a flashy costume so he
gets attention to feed his gigantic
insatiable ego now if i'm a mentally
unstable person and i see him getting
all this coverage what am i going to do
it's called copycat behavior people and
it's ruining new york
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
gave me her cell number when she finally
decided to trust me
she's risking a lot
if anyone finds out she's helping me
she'll lose her job
[Music]
wow
someone's getting robbed
who wants a picture
and no more markers
i love a happy ending thank you
nice to know someone's still looking out
for us spidey
uh
[Music]
all eunice a break-in was just reported
additional officers requested near
flatiron
[Music]
hello
man fist goes away and suddenly it's
amateur hour
come on
get down
[Music]
[Music]
so they're all going to jail where i bet
you'll be as good at breaking out as you
were at breaking it
so
herman
long time no see
hey i'm no lawyer but uh i'm pretty sure
that's a parole violation
oops guess we're stuck in here for a
while want to play 20 questions
no
how about we thumb rest
okay face punch it is
yeah
whoa your gauntlets are all digital now
aren't they have it your way you wanna
fight let's fight
man can't wait to put you back behind
bars so we can talk science
remember our first fight
me so young and stupid
you just stupid
well that's a matter of opinion i mean
is there any standard men okay now i can
do some real danger
why are you doing this herman in front
of my dope don't kill me
if you come clean i can help you you
really want to help me
sorry not gonna happen
you know people don't use banks anymore
you're lucky you found actual cash
if you really want to rob banks
try day trading it's all the
ah rage on herman
if you tell me who you're working for i
can help you cut a deal if i [ __ ] i'm
dead they made that very clear
you're freaking me out herman it's not
like you to be afraid of people not even
sure these guys
could be anything
wait did you say masks
these masked guys what do they want the
money for
no no don't care
oh
give up now and we can protect you no
way
you ain't see
okay last chance to give up this time i
really mean it
okay i was kidding before
now is your last last chance seriously
sorry herman
you brought this on yourself
literally
man
he was scared and desperate
these demons are everywhere all of a
sudden